[Música]
en cultura de france 24 hoy nos rendimos
al sumo poeta de la historia durante día
liguero day alighieri más conocido como
dante el también pensador y político
florentino alcanzó este 2021 el
settecento aniversario de una muerte por
malaria bajo exilio y repudio que no se
asemeja a su inmortalidad
dante desnudo su mente en la vida nueva
defendió la separación iglesia imperio
en de monarquía pero su comedia
adjetivada divina por boccaccio fue su
infierno y su cima fue base del italiano
en camino el humanismo y aún ahora es la
obra más moderna que se haya escrito
y
hoy leemos a dante por sus grandes
historias francesca o gol y noticias por
ejemplo volviendo a editar el texto
recortando los por razones prácticas y
volviendo a ofrecer la historia un
relato de redención del mal al bien la
experiencia de un hombre que se enfrenta
a la degradación de la vida el
sufrimiento para crecer y experimentar
con la más alta experiencia de la visión
de dios
es un viaje moral profundo es útil
conocerlo desde un punto de vista
didáctico pero también un punto de vista
moral es una experiencia sumamente
envolvente y poderosa capaz de enseñar
también un viaje espiritual que enseña
un profuso spank espiritual la génesis
del proyecto tanto el puesto eterno
nadie da a una la génesis del proyecto
dante y el poeta eterno empezó como una
necesidad personal de acercar a las
nuevas generaciones el pensamiento la
historia y la vida de dante y de la
divina comedia más o producto micro
lleva muchísimo poder pero sobre todo es
la historia de un hombre capaz de amar a
una mujer después de todo desde su
exilio dante supo crear los versos más
importantes de todos y una historia de
amor que aún se respira es una sagrada
morgan corazón y respira para considerar
su legado y su poema sacro hoy nos
acompaña el ensayista y erudito pablo
moret gracias pablo por estar
precisamente con conexión desde la
ciudad natal de dante
muchas gracias por invitarme pablo de no
haber sido desterrado por su cargo de
prior y por su rechazo al papa bonifacio
octavo estaríamos hablando de dante
hubiera hecho ese peregrinaje por esta
comedia
bueno es muy difícil decirlo pero yo
creo que no sin embargo la muerte de
beatrice que fue algo que sucedió antes
de su condena al exilio quizás se podría
decir que es el acontecimiento más
importante de su vida y el que los lleva
a escribir la comedia pero la
experiencia del exilio es fundamental
para que dante componga no solo la
comedia sino la mayor parte de sus obras
salvo la vita nuova
es vox populi que su obra se mantiene
porque hablan desde el yo del mundo de
la miseria de la amistad con virgilio de
la salvación es decir pero en cierto
modo me gustaría saber si hay un ajuste
de cuentas sobre la definición de
justicia
bueno creo que si hay un ajuste de
cuentas dante en el fondo como todo gran
poeta sabía que lo era y
esperaba cierto reconocimiento y también
esperaba el reconocimiento de su ciudad
que tan vilmente lo expulsó y lo despojó
de todos sus bienes entonces creo que
hay una justicia en la fama que ha
logrado que es la forma más alta quizás
que cualquier poeta jamás logrado de
florencia siempre se recrimina haberlo
expulsado
mencionabas pablo a beatrice smooth
angelica tavera que se enamoró y vio
morir muy pronto y precisamente ya
aparece en el paraíso no es el amor de
beatrice el motor del ayer
si
absolutamente desde su primera obra la
vida nueva hasta el paraíso el motor que
lo mueve es el amor de beatrice que es
un deseo
completo digamos empieza en el cuerpo
entra por los ojos pero después se
vuelve una virtud que empuja el alma
hacia la ascendencia
y no hace mejorar digamos moralmente y
lo hace subir hasta las más altas
esferas de lo divino siempre beatrice el
motor que lo que lo mueve en ciertos
sentidos se parece bastante al aleros
del que hablaba platón es ese impulso
hacia las esferas superiores de la
existencia
solo mirando lo literario que hace
icónicos estos 100 encantos de 14.233
versos endecasílabos en toscana que allí
asienta también la base de la actual
italiana el triunfo es que todo esto sea
una poesía
si si uno lo lee es ese
el gran misterio de la obra dancística
que funciona a tantos niveles y le habla
a tanta gente tan distinta a los mayores
eruditos y a la gente más simple que
quizás ni siquiera tiene la costumbre de
la lectura dante habla desde un show que
es muy moderno y a la vez es
profundamente medieval profundamente de
un hombre de su tiempo entonces conjuga
lo universal y luego absolutamente
particular y las historias que cuenta
son muy humanas son los personajes que
evocan los podemos casi escuchar y
sentir y tocar tiene una claridad una
economía y un rigor una perspicacia en
el lenguaje que vuelve todo lo que
cuenta absolutamente tangible y nos
ubica a nosotros mismos en ese mundo lo
acompañamos desde la primera línea que
dice el camino de nuestra vida somos
nosotros no es el solo
sin que parezca que te estoy mandando al
infierno dantesco o al oratorio me
permitirá es preguntarte qué círculo o
pasaje es de tu mayor interés o el que
más te ha marcado
creo que el episodio de ulises es el que
siempre me impresiona más sobre todo
también va por su por su modernidad
porque ulises habla de ésta y de esta
experiencia que le pide a sus hombres
que no le nieguen no me nieguen la
experiencia de conocer el mundo
desconocido de ir más allá de los
límites muchos han leído acá una
anticipación del impulso que llevará a
los europeos a conquistar el nuevo mundo
entonces ahí en ulises en esta idea de
la novedad y de la experiencia me veo
una un poder visionario gigante
además de buscar eso también es un el
infierno de dante lo dantesco es algo
que está en nuestra religión por ejemplo
también es algo que nos ha dejado el
como imaginario
si ha creado una manera de entender el
mundo ultraterreno la ultratumba que ha
marcado para siempre la religión
cristiana y no solo puede también en el
infierno de dante está por ejemplo el
profeta mahoma
en el parc en el paraíso están ciertos
patriarcas del antiguo testamento
entonces su marca en la religión las
tres grandes religiones del libro es
gigantesca ni hablar también en las
religiones paganas y anteriores que
informan toda su obra
precisamente en los siglos 19 y 20 su
figura vemos que se ha celebrado desde
lo religioso o como un prócer de la
unidad italiana por todo este legado
como se ha representado este este centro
pandémico que además lo estás viviendo
desde florencia
si es bueno es impresionante en cada
ciudad italiana en cada pueblo hay
celebraciones hay lecturas hay muestras
de arte hay
instalaciones en realmente en todos
lados hasta en los pueblos más pequeños
creo que dante en el settecento
aniversario es un poeta multimedia
porque lo que se experimenta con todos
los medios posibles y se habla también
de su versatilidad que da lugar a que se
lo adapte de tantas maneras distintas
así que ya no es tanto el nacionalismo
ni la religión sino él es el gran poeta
de la era multimedia
que hubiese pensado dante de ver ser
reflejado por ejemplo en una de las
proyecciones enormes que hemos visto con
dibujos de gustave doré o que hubiese
imaginado que crees pablo
yo creo que le hubiera encantado porque
era un hombre brillante un genio y los
genios suelen ser muy curiosos y muy
apasionados de la novedad y hubiera
resultado fascinante quizás también un
poco terrorífico pero seguramente
fascinante
mi siguiente pregunta sería más bien
como el ejemplo tanto es que justo
mencionábamos ha gustado gustado g pero
aquí también tenemos en nuestro estudio
a dalí representado como dante ha
inspirado a la cultura no porque también
hay videojuegos hay el clásico filme del
infierno como lo consideras tú como cómo
ha sido esa inspiración
y creo que precisamente dante da para
todo el primero que el argumento de la
comedia el argumento del viaje es uno de
los más amados por los seres humanos
digamos los nuevos clásicos de la
literatura es el viaje y sobre todo un
viaje al la ultratumba donde uno se
encuentra con distintos personajes los
personajes fuertes inolvidables que van
armando la historia tiene todos los
elementos para para hacer un texto con
el que nos compenetramos un texto
inolvidable que da para muchísimo más
y finalmente para cerrar pablo los
restos de dante descansan en rávena a
voluntad propia después de su exilio
crees que florencia mantiene el dolor de
haberlo enjuiciado y doblemente como
amenazado de muerte
sí sin duda y florencia no sé si todos
los años pero cada tanto le pide a
rávena que devuelva a los restos hay una
tumba en la iglesia de santa croce de
florencia vacía un mausoleo esperando
los restos de dante pero yo creo que esa
vena nunca los va a entregar porque de
dante murió ahí y murió feliz con su
familia y florencia lo expulsó y se
merecen obtener sus restos tendrás
redención en algún momento en algún
siglo estaremos hablando de que
finalmente éste ha sido redimido de ello
quién sabe yo creo que puede ser bueno
el derrotero de los huesos de dante
todavía tiene mucho que recorrer pues
muchísimas gracias pablo por tu
presencia en este especial para recordar
a una figura mundialmente y cumbre de la
literatura universal muchísimas gracias
por estar desde florencia y ya todos
ustedes les agradecemos su compañía y
sobre todo que siguen leyendo al gran
maestro al sumo poeta
[Música]